[Music]
beehives on roofs in rome in order to
pollinate our plants and crops
sheep grazing in town to encourage new
ecosystems
a kitchen garden overlooking the eiffel
tower to bring some greenery into the
city
projects like these boosting
biodiversity in cities have become
even more important since the pandemic
[Music]
is
reintroducing biodiversity into urban
areas is part of eu strategy
the european parliament says we need to
do more in order to turn the tide on
biodiversity loss
global heating is taking its toll on our
habitats and ecosystems
today human activity is threatening one
million species worldwide
the eu has the world's largest network
of designated natural areas
but our seas forests and ecosystems
still need better protection from human
activity
about
parliament wants to stop the decline of
pollinators such as bees
a vital link in our food chain members
will oppose the reauthorization of the
herbicide glyphosate in the eu
after 2022 mep say
20 billion euros per year and binding
rules are needed to protect europe's
habitats and biodiversity
just like the eu's climate targets
they're also calling for a global
agreement for biodiversity at the un
conference in october 2021